ktv mit luca bist du nicht willig reden
bitte bürgersteig hier steht ein war
auch wegen der straße denkt da ich ja
als motiv für die mit fahrrädern
unterwegs oder mit rollern
vor
jetzt sei dir als 10
ich bin schon 14 ich grüß martin piller
und jonas kiefer
formstabile man trägt oder irgendwas
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo
[Musik]
hallo hallo
das geht ja selbstverständlich kost aber
30 euro in sekunden später
foto gemacht
perfekt hat es mir geld einfach
überweisen dann besonders nicht bei mir
und möchte mich bei facetime anruf da
kannst du was sagen wenn du möchtest
[Musik]
das kann ich sagen dies eigentlich nicht
so cool wo wir spazieren gegangen sind
ja komm wir nur zugeguckt wie ich
gegangen bin und du bereit bist was isst
du gerade
ich dachte nur zwei oder so ich bin fix
und tschüss
[Musik]
innerhalb von meinem stuhl runter aber
trocken
auf dem mond oder warum sind da die
sterbe er wir sind hier voll
colourblocking unterwegs ich so komplett
blau du so rotierten schwarzen rudi im
hintergrund des gelber doch zusehen wie
geht es euch geht es auch sehr gut danke
ich war denn der staat
weihnachtsgeschenke ein gekauft habt ihr
schon weihnachtsgeschenke meine beste
freundin oder ausrasten wenn sie dich
sehen würde sie liebt dich über alles
soll ich lehne aber instagram videos
schicken wir haben gerade ein paar
sekunden später hat mir sogar schon eine
nachricht geschrieben und zwar sehr viel
geschrieben geht ich doch mal
untersuchen lassen ob du gerade haben
[Musik]
wir auch mit tv wieder alles ein
geschenk von dir was ein merger das ist
so geil alles ach hätte ich mal was doch
ausgebracht vor weihnachten hätte ich
viel gewinn gemacht
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
liegt das board oben auf dem schrank
oder was also von hier aus wie spongebob
mit seiner krawatte da was geht wie
geht's dir auch gut danke ich glaube ich
hab die gleichen rolladen wie du da ist
der bierflasche hier rechts okay das ist
schon tricks ihr bierchen oder so
bekannten getrunken
brutale
[Musik]
als schweizer fan von gastro voll viele
leute die an waldböden 13 trinkt bier
aber damals mainz checke ich nicht so
hallo
das hallo
[Musik]
was geht
ich hab ich nicht nein danke bitte schön
es gibt mal ehrlich echt dass es nicht
klappt sprachenlernen sieht man dass
momentan was machst du auch gut das
machst du schöne damals einfach
ich wollte katz ich wollte ihr mann wie
einfach es ist mit
[Musik]
da bräuchte war tipps sind thema mädchen
klärt ich bin single bruder das erst
muss macht egal was ist sagt zuerst
falschen alter du musst es war sein
erster bist du wenn ich fragen darf oder
wie heißt du auf jeden fall habe ich
will ich will das system automatisch von
mir erwarte man guckt ja noch drängeln
de luca ja ich glaube wenn ich jetzt
noch mal instagram gehen wer dich
rausgeschmissen ja ich glaube schon du
kannst du einfach eine dm schreiben ich
bin dort schon instagram drinnen kannst
du einfach nur schreiben dann packe ich
das mache hier rein also ich packe jetzt
sogar daher sicht mag ich deinen armen
leute volk gehen und jungen der
witzigste junge den ich hier auf die wir
getroffen haben
wie heißt überhaupt muss selber gucken
wie dein name ist nicht ein instagram
name hast mein echter auch leoni leoni
gibt nicht die ganze zeit als noel aus
also du fängst ein alter und deinen
namen vermitteln
ich wünsch dir was schreibt mir auf den
sack
vor einiger zeit schöne grüße aber immer
für sie da wird werde ich heute hier wie
so oft vor da um die wir auch nicht es
waren dann wieder solche blech menschen
unterwegs allein dieser neonet oder noel
lee am ende der zehn jahre alt ist aber
wenn mädels wahrscheinlich mal sagt dass
er 35 ist unternehmer hat mir wieder
mega viel spaß macht die heutige folge
schalteten daumen hoch und das video
wenn ihr mehr bock auf augen tv videos
auf einem kanal hat umschreibt man in
die kommentare
die hat ihr seid interessiert mich gar
nicht
[Musik]